former navi igl boomich is back the news
after appearing in a tell-all interview
he gave a more detailed account of his
side of the story regarding his drop
from na'vi his public divorce and
alleged drug use the story continues to
be both wild and extremely serious so
let's unpack what we've learned
in case you missed it we already did a
video covering the booming situation a
couple weeks ago so go check that one
out if you want to get up to date before
continuing this one regardless i'll give
you the long and short of it na'vi
dropped russian cs go pro boomage over
reputation issues then his ex-wife
angelica accused him of physical abuse
and being a drug addict before releasing
a video of boomi snorting an unknown
white powder boomich then claimed that
his ex-wife was blackmailing him and he
was going to sue her for libel since
then things have been mostly quiet that
was until a russian content creator by
the name of ryze released an almost
40-minute tell-all interview with
boomich in the video boomage breaks down
the entire situation from his point of
view and even talks about his future in
cs but before we break this down i want
to make it clear that parts of this
interview can come across as
unusual to say the least
[Music]
so what did we find out well basically
goes over his entire relationship from
start to chaotic finish so strap in to
start off he states that the two met on
an escort service and he immediately
grew fond of angelica but shortly after
the two started dating the relationship
would become played with constant
fighting and numerous breakups both
public and private regardless booming
said that he wanted to make things work
with angelica and was even willing to
help raise her child he even promised to
marry her if he ever won a major what
yeah
later in the interview the host asks
boomich about the photos of his ex
supposedly supporting russia during the
invasion boomish says that was the most
difficult time for him and he urged his
ex not to post anything pro-russian
since it would jeopardize his career
boomish then claims that him getting
kicked from navi was entirely due to
angelica's provocative posts and nothing
else now when it comes to the video of
boomits doing an illicit drug he
confirms that it's him but says it was
an old video he then claims that he only
did it once didn't like it and is quote
against drugs
in mexico
in the case for the alleged blackmailing
boomic says that during one of the
divorce proceedings angelica took his
phone and looked through it trying to
find something to hold against him now
before we continue i want to remind you
guys this isn't just a cs gopro who
played at the highest tier this is a man
who's coming off of a major win we have
literally never seen this much personal
information get aired before it's
unprecedented boomish later said in the
interview that angelica screamed at him
in public for more money and ripped the
gold chain off his neck pretty briefly
the allegations of abuse he's currently
facing which are definitely the most
important in this entire case well
boomers revealed that the two are
actually going to court over the alleged
domestic violence and it seems to be in
relation to angelica's claims that
boomish knocked her tooth out in the
interview boomer said that he already
went to the police and explained his
side of the story he claims that
angelica has a false tooth and lost it
in the shower but twisted the story to
make it seem like boomich knocked it out
now to our knowledge angelica hasn't
followed up with any specifics regarding
her side of the story her claims are
still the same boomich knocked out her
tooth also keep in mind that as of
recording this video we have no idea how
far along they are in the court process
the interview ends with boomag saying
that he still has a passion for cs go
and wants to play at the highest level
again boomish also says that after
looking at his bank statements he
believes he transferred angelica roughly
28 million rubles during their
relationship which comes out to around
half a million dollars
options
since the interview was posted on
youtube angelica made several posts on
her telegram in response when it comes
to the money side of things angelica hid
back claiming that it was through her
help that boomich earned over 100
million rupees in salary prize money and
stickers she still holds firm that
boomich did drugs more often and more
recently than he lets on and is willing
to show the dates of the video and
claims that she's been invited to an
interview to tell her side of the story
there was also an eyebrow raising moment
where angelica suggests that if boomich
played like simple then navi wouldn't
have parted ways with in her words a
drug addict like him she also urged for
girls to be careful and avoid situations
like the one she's in but also levied
some pretty homophobic statements
towards boomich later angelica made
another post stating that everything she
said was true but also pleaded for
boomage to move on saying that the past
is in the past and they shouldn't dwell
upon it she said that she put her life
back together from nothing and that
boomich should do the same but why do we
care why is this important to see us go
well to put it bluntly this situation is
crazy we've never seen anything like
this in professional cs go before
especially nothing this public and it's
going to be interesting to see what orgs
do in the coming months like i said
earlier boomish says he wants to return
to the same level of play he was at
before he's only 23 and led a team to a
major that's why i think he did this
interview not to drag his ex through the
mud or clear his name in the eyes of his
peers he wants orgs to see this and
think that this whole situation is not
one that makes him unsignable in the
future now i'm not saying he's going to
magically join eg's 15-man roster a lot
of this hinges on how things go in court
we still don't know when the results of
that are going to appear but a lot hangs
in the balance of that court's decision
and just like everything else in this
story it all seems up in the air
you